can we talk about Ukraine sure you have
a disagreement with UK uh with with what
uh Destiny said my my main problem with
Biden's policy with regard to Ukraine is
that he outsourced the end goal of the
war to zalinsky early on now that might
make sense if that goal were something
that he was willing to fund to the point
of achievement uh or if zinski could
have achieved it on his own but right
now and this has been true since pretty
early on the war Point Henry Kissinger
made uh this that that pretty early on
in the war it was very clear that for
example Crimea was going nowhere the
Russians had control of Crimea barring
the United States giving permission to
fly f-16s over Crimea nothing was going
to change over there the same thing was
true in most of the donbass right in
luhansk and DK that that was not going
to change zinsky stated goal and you
understand it he's the leader of Ukraine
right is is that there was a predation
on his territory in 2014 and that the
Russians sent their little green men
across the border and then they took all
of these areas and so he is the leader
of Ukraine is saying okay I want all of
that back now the reality is that the
US's interest had largely been achieved
in the first few months of the war
meaning the revocation of the ability of
Russia to take Ukraine and just ingest
it and two the devastation of of
Russia's military capability I mean
Russia has just been wrecked I mean
their military is in serious Straits
because of the war in Ukraine from an
American perspective I'm very much Pro
all of that I think that we have an
interest in Ukraine maintaining a buffer
status against territorially aggressive
Russia I think that the United States
does have an interest in degrading the
Russian military to the extent that it
can't threaten the Baltic states or
threaten Kazakhstan or other countries
in the region the problem I have with
Biden's strategy is as always I think
that it's a muddle and I think mdels
tend to end with misperceptions war
tends to break out and maintain because
of misperception misperception of the
other side's strength the other side's
intentions and and all of the rest
people misperceive what's going to
happen they say I I'll cross that line
and nothing will happen right this is
what Putin thought he thought I'll cross
that line they will greet me as a
liberator and because the United States
just surrendered in Afghanistan
essentially they won't do anything and
the West is fragmenting because NATO's
fragmenting and all the rest of this and
obviously he was wrong on on all those
scores the problem for for Biden is that
as with virtually every war no end line
was set and so it became out recently it
was widely reported that actually there
was a peace deal that was on the table
in the first few months that Putin was
on board with uh that basically would
have seeded luhansk and denet and Crimea
to Russia in return for solidification
of those lines American and Western
Security guarantees to Ukraine right
Ukraine wouldn't formally join NATO but
there would be security guarantees to
Ukraine we're ending up there anyway
it's just taking a lot more money and a
lot more time to get there and do you
think Trump would have helped push that
piece yes and I think and I think that
Biden actually did zalinski a bit of a
disservice because zinski knows where
this war is going to end and it's not
going to end with lanskin denes and
Crimea in Ukrainian hands it's just not
going to and he knows that what actually
in my opinion zalinski needed was for
Joe Biden to be the person who foed that
deal upon him so that he could then go
back to his own people and say listen
guys I wanted all those things but the
Americans weren't willing to allow me to
have all those things and so we did an
amazing job we did a heroic job in
defending our own land we devastated the
Russian military even though no one
expected us to but we can't get back
those things because it's unrealistic to
get back to those things because America
basically they're big funer and they're
the ones who want the deal instead what
Biden said and this was reported in the
Washington Post last year the Biden
Administration said we're going to fight
for as long long as it takes with as
much as it takes and when they were
asked until when they said whatever
zinsky says and that's not a policy
that's just a recipe for a frozen
conflict with endless funding now it may
be that Putin's walked away from the
table and that deal is no longer
available if that deal is is available
right now I certainly hope that's being
pursued behind closed doors my main
critique again of Biden is that when you
Outsource the end goal to another
country without stating what America's
interest is that's a problem I also
think that did really quite a poor job
of sort of explaining what America's
realistic interests are I I I don't like
it when American leaders um it's weird
for me to say this but I'm not a huge
fan of the we're in it to protect
democracy kind of rhetoric because
frankly we are allied with many many
countries that are not democracies and
that's not actually how foreign policy
Works uh we should as an overall you
know 30,000 foot goal Advance democracy
and and rights where we can but the
reason that we were
fighting and in favor of Ukraine and
when I say fighting I mean giving them
money and giving them Weaponry the
reason that we were doing that in favor
of Ukraine is not because of Ukraine's
long history of clean voting and non-c
Corruption the reason that we were doing
that is to counter Russian interests in
the region I mean that was it was a pure
real politique play and that real
politic play is hard to deny no matter
what side of the aisle you're on I think
that what many Americans are going to
are reverting to is we have no interest
there why are we spending the money
there and not spending the money here
and that that kind of stuff and that
that argument can always be applied
unless you actually articulate like the
reason why it is good for Americans
Beyond simply the ideological for the
United States to be involved in a thing
so for example I think right now when
when Biden is talk I think that what
Biden just did he's the United States as
we speak is striking the houthis I think
that that's a really really good thing I
think that's a necessary thing I think
American people should understand why
that is happening it's not because of
quote unquote ideology it is I mean on a
on a very root level but really it's
because you're you're screwing up the
Straits I mean you can't you can't do
that you can't screw up free trade and
Americans have an interest in not seeing
all of our prices at the grocery store
double and triple because a bunch of rag
tag Pirates you know akin to the the
barber pirates from 1800 are are
bothering everyone right so Ben said a
lot there do you disagree with any
aspect on the Ukraine side the um a
little bit yeah um I think on the macro
I agree maybe we get to the we a little
bit on some things I on the final thing
that he said though I wish that
Americans could have honest
conversations about foreign policy I
think that it would just be better for
everybody um I don't know if it's uh you
know Red Scare after the Cold War where
it was like literally you know you know
the behemoths you know we're fighting
against communism and we felt like after
91 every single foreign policy decision
needs to be able to be explained in like
seven words like he's the bad guy and
that's it um I wish we had more honest
conversations about uh what our foreign
policy interest is in a particular
region because I don't think most
Americans honestly could even articulate
why Israel would be an important Ally or
why it's important to defend Ukraine
against Russia or why should we care
about Taiwan at all I don't know if most
Americans could articulate anything
there um even though they might have
very strong opinions about why uh we
ought to be involved in certain
conflicts so I do agree with that I wish
we had more honest conversations about
uh foreign policy um in terms of how
Biden has handled Ukraine my the things
that I liked the most were one that he
was very clear in the beginning about
what we wouldn't do so Biden saying that
we're not going to do um uh not a red
line no fly zones over Ukraine we're not
going to be deploying troops on the
ground in Ukraine we're not going to be
doing anything that would have you know
US soldiers and Russian soldiers
crossing swords with each other that's
not going to happen I like that he made
made that very clear at the beginning um
and I like that the Coalition built
between NATO and the EU to get people to
send uh funds training soldiers
airplanes and everything to Ukraine I
thought those two things are really good
in terms of basically writing zalinsky
blank check I would like to hope that
Biden and the entire United States
learned a lesson from Iraq and
Afghanistan that open-ended missions
with unlimited budgets and no clear goal
are like the worst foreign policy
decisions you can ever do they've like
defined US foreign policy for theast two
or three decades which is unfortunate
but seems to be the case um my my
feeling would be and this is just a
feeling I don't know if internal cables
have leaked that say otherwise is the uh
the Biden Administration has probably
always had a quiet position of at some
point there's going to be an off-ramp
here and I think even a month or two ago
I think those talks were being leaked
that discussion had begun with zalinsky
looking for an off-ramp but publicly of
course the United States is never going
to come out and say we're going to
support you guys to fight as much as you
want for three months and then after
that it's no more obviously that can't
be the statement it's always going to be
that we're going to support you in your
fight against Russia we tried that under
Obama with Afghanistan it was terrible
sure yeah you can't we'll escalate The
Troop levels to X but only for six
months and then we're yeah you can't you
just can't do that it's always going to
come off as we're going to support you
forever and as long as it takes and as
long as you need whatever we have to do
to defend freedom and democracy in your
country and any any other statement
would be absurd so I can understand why
it feels like on a public level a blank
check and an indefinite time period was
granted to zalinski but I don't think
that's going to be the case I I again I
hope we've learned our lessons in the
Middle East about the forever Wars that
this isn't going to be a forever funding
to Ukraine to fight for as long as they
want um I do disagree I feel like we're
playing a little bit retrospectively
saying that like well it's obvious that
they're not going to capture the Don BOS
it's obvious that they're not going to
capture Crimea I agree for Crimea that
was incredibly obvious but it was also
really obvious that in two weeks Russia
would own Kiev and Ukraine was going to
be bellarus 2.0 I think that even for a
lot of uh military people um and
analysts around the world uh that that
that was an expectation or at least a
significant probability nobody knew uh
the phrase that's thr around now is
paper tiger that Russia's military was
as ill equipped as they were so I can
understand why especially if you're
Ukraine and if you've repelled an
invasion from one of the world's largest
armies why you might feel like well [__]
it you know let's fight for a few months
let's fight for a year let's see what
happens and I can understand the United
States supporting them but I agree that
there has to be some reasonable off ramp
where we're not going to fight forever I
think the US um state department has
already begun those conversations with
zinsky to look at what that off-ramp
looks like um but yeah I'm not too sure
other than like explicitly stating
publicly like you can only fight until
this date I don't really know what else
I would change I don't think I don't
think the Biden Administration should
have done that I I don't know what else
do you think Biden should cut this deal
on uh on the funding meaning there's
like six there's this $ 105 billion deal
that's been held up by debate between
Republicans and Democrats over border
right so basically it contains $60
billion for ukraine4 billion for Israel
another several billion dollars for
taiwan's defense against China and then
include some border funding and some
border Provisions Republicans want the
Border funding and the Border Provisions
because we can get into the illegal
immigration issue but that's pretty
serious issue and Biden and Democrats
have been unwilling to hold that up and
that that seems to me like just from put
aside Republican Democrat it seems like
political malpractice meaning there's a
widespread perception in the United
States that the border is a disaster
area Joe Biden wants these things many
Republicans don't want these things if
he caves On the Border stuff he gets all
the things that he wants and he's going
to be able to go back to the moderates
in the country and say I did something
about the Border it seems like such an
obvious win if he caves On the Border
stuff you mean on the Ukraine stuff yes
because then he gets the whole
go own sayen IED wanted to Bey on the
the Republicans forc me to it but we
needed the Ukraine we needed the Taiwan
you're honestly you're going to be more
educated than me on this I don't like uh
or maybe maybe I just don't know enough
I don't like the principle that when we
negotiate things in the United States
there's like 50 million hostages at all
points in time for every single thing
like oh boy here comes the debt ceiling
what are the Republicans want what do
the Democrats want oh boy like here you
know we can't fund our government um but
I mean obviously the the argument is
going to be that if the Ukraine funding
doesn't come in this bill and if Biden
and his administration feel like it's
really important that unil or not
unilaterally but as a single issue it's
not going to pass so um I would say that
at this point and I don't know what the
conversations look like between the bid
Administration and zinsky I would say at
this point that it's probably fair to
start making contingencies on the money
that we give to Ukraine that listen like
this uh conflict has you know waged on
now like now we need to start looking
for potential peace we can't just write
you an unlimited check so I mean if
those strings are attached I'd be okay
with it but the broader question of like
is it okay to make this particular piece
of legislation with all this funding
contingent on uh the Ukrainian funding I
mean that just seems to be the way the
government works now
unfortunately